what's your favorite game one that you
would describe yourself as a fan of now
for me it would have to be Skyrim but do
you love your favorite game enough to
pay several hundred dollars on tickets
accommodation and flights to a country
on the edge of the Arctic Circle to hang
out with other players of the game swap
stories and have a big old party well
you know what you might if your game of
choice is EVE Online thousands of the
spacefaring fans attended fan fest this
year held an Iceland's capital Reykjavik
it's a celebration of all things in the
EVE universe a setting for developers
and players to mix swap stories and just
generally have a good time but what is
going on in our human brains that can
make players of a game so passionate so
loyal so fanatical
now if you haven't heard of EVE Online
it's a massively multiplayer online game
played by over half a million people now
what sets the game apart from other MMOs
is that everyone plays in this same
universe on a single shard so I figured
what better community to use as a case
study to investigate the psychology of
what makes people feel and behave like
fans for me the key to Eve is definitely
the community I mean the people who
always play together and you can hate
your guts one day and just love each
other the next it's an absolutely
awesome feeling and if I let everything
in Eve is seated from the players makes
it even more awesome because everything
is created by us for our game as many a
community and it's really a sandbox
thing that really appeals to me the fact
that whenever you do something you're
messing up someone else's life I think
it's just the community you make friends
and you make enemies you play other
games there's no repercussions for
losing this you lose something and it
burns and you try to lick your wounds
and come back with a little smarter
hopefully and and and move from there
now being a fan of a thing is generally
a positive experience this is
predominately because we get a great
feeling of oneness when we connect to
other people when we self-identify as
part of a group so why is this well a
prominent and established theory of
human psychology and one I've talked
about before on reality check is the
idea of self-determination theory this
gives us an insight into our motivations
why we do things according to the theory
we are all motivated to be competent
autonomous and importantly for us today
and related to other people now this
ties into exactly what those fans were
saying about why they enjoy the games so
much it's all about the community in the
world of social psychology we treat a
group which we belong to as an in-group
one that we self-identify with an
out-group on the other hand is one you
don't belong to now our own innate human
psychology means that we unwittingly tie
our self-esteem end with any group that
we join so not only do we favor
that group and talk it up but we will
actively discriminate against other
groups putting them down in comparison
and an effort to protect our own
self-esteem investment scientific
research has demonstrated this by simply
dividing a number of individuals random
into two groups and then giving them
time to bond people will then actively
favour those members of their own group
and behave derisively towards members of
the other group based on nothing at all
other than the random assignment to that
group in the first place
now I also put the question of what
makes Eve fans so loyal to the game
developers ccp's chief marketing officer
and all-round cheerful chap David read
to see what he thought you literally are
impacting every other player with
everything that you do because everyone
is playing on the same shard together
everyone is in this sandbox style of
design there is a very robust high
fidelity virtual economy under it and
what this means in the end is that as an
Eve player right I get to understand
that this is a game where I really make
a difference right my choices have real
consequences my actions have impact
there is no George Lucas of EVE Online
who is like here's the story here are
the stars here's how it's going to go no
it is all in the hands of the players
this sandbox environment is also crucial
to encouraging a committed fanbase
existing in a world where you can see
that your actions matter and that what
you do makes a difference is really
important in helping to create the
feeling of contingency without this our
illusion of the world can quickly fall
apart and break the relationship we feel
with the game this also fosters a sense
of ownership and fans regularly refer to
Eve as their game this ties into
something called the environment affect
which hypothesizes the people ascribe
more value to things merely because they
own them a lovely little experiment
demonstrated this idea by splitting
participants into two groups one group
were merely shown a mug by a researcher
who kept it in their hands and the other
group were allowed to hold it and told
that they in fact know all the mug both
groups were then asked how much they
would pay for the mug now the second
group who felt they had ownership gave
the mug more than double the
on average compared to the first group
so by giving players control you helped
foster ownership which in turn can lead
to them ascribing it with a higher value
at least that's the theory now if you
talk to anyone who's tried to play Eve
and failed you undoubtedly hear that the
game was just too hard or just too
complicated so I asked David if he
thought that this barrier for entry this
degree of exclusivity might also be
playing a role we are proud to be a
company of adults making core games for
adults who are core gamers and there is
a certain amount of challenge that you
know is part of being a gamer right I
like having I like having bars set and
surpassing them and more and more games
today are are shying away from that
they're there they're making the hurdles
lighter to appeal to broader and larger
audiences the problem with that is those
people never become terribly loyal right
you're either a gamer with a capital G
or you're not and at the end of the day
if you're a gamer and times get tough
you're gonna eat mac and cheese and
ramen noodles to feed your gaming habit
but if you're one of these casual gamers
and times get tough the games are the
first thing to go
all this further engenders that in-group
feeling of we are better than them
plus it can also help to achieve
cognitive flow flow is the feeling of
focus of being in the zone and it's at
its most powerful at the point where
high difficulty and high player skill
level meet pretty much a perfect
description of the Eve online universe
so it appears that games like EVE Online
which provide a strong community gave
ownership and which set a high challenge
are really well suited to encouraging
exceptionally dedicated fans but what do
you reckon can you think of a different
game which does this even better let me
know in the comments last week on
reality check said for to the reins and
investigated the limits of superhuman
strength to quickly recap Seb explained
that our bodies really have two levels
of the most that we can lift maximal
strength being the most we can lift with
conscious efforts and an absolute
strength the most our bodies can
physically handle before falling to
pieces now the average person's maximal
strength as Seb explained is roughly two
thirds of their absolute strength but
how about power lifters as YouTube
commenter mr. bit viper asked well if
you are a serious power lifter the type
you enters competitions and spend most
days there in the gym that potential
increase of a third would in fact be
much much less in fact you might be able
to lift closer to 80% of your absolute
strength already just with conscious
effort due to practice and perfect
technique and if you want to contact me
about this episode or have a suggestion
for a future topic then probably the
best way is to get in touch with me on
twitter i'm at camp Fras robb ok thanks
for watching folks see you next week
you